and we begin with breaking news this
morning the former metropolitan police
officer wayne cousins
has pleaded guilty at the old bailly to
the kidnap and rape
of sarah everard he also admitted
responsibility for her killing
but he was not asked to enter a plea to
the charge of
murder sarah who was 33 years old
vanished while walking home from a
friend's house
in clapham south london in march well
let's get more now
from our home affairs correspondent mark
white and mark
significant development this but still
quite a lot of
legal issues to be resolved
yeah some very heavy reporting
restrictions around this case as you
would imagine adam as it's still very
much an active
case uh wayne cousins appeared
via video link at the old bailey this
morning for
a short hearing of about 20 minutes or
so
where two of the three counts were put
to him
uh the first uh count that was put to
him the kidnappers here at everard on
the third of march
this year uh wayne cousins pleaded
guilty
to that count a second count of the rape
of sarah everard between the 2nd
of march and the 10th of march
was also put to wayne cousins and again
he
pleaded guilty to that count a third
kind of murder
was not put to wayne cousins at this
stage there will be
a further court hearing on the 9th of
july however
uh the legal team for wayne cousins
said that he did accept responsibility
for the killings uh as i say that third
count though will not be put uh
to win cousins certainly wasn't today
and there is that
further hearing on the 9th of july as
you mentioned in your introduction there
adam
um sarah everard disappeared uh while
walking home the third
of march uh this year there was a huge
policeman hunt uh for miss everard uh
and her body was then found some seven
days later
in woodland near ashford in kent
wayne cousins serving police officer
with the parliamentary and diplomatic
protection command of the metropolitan
police was then subsequently arrested
and charged as i say that case now
active we await
another court hearing on the 9th of july
but today
in an indication in court from his legal
team that he accepted
responsibility for sarah everard's
killing however that third count of
murder was not put to him at this stage